You are listening to
radio lab radio from W N.
Y. S. T. E. Yep.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today a story that
we've been working on for close to two
years, but just before you're about
to put on the air, this happened
[inaudible]
the next story in perspective, it's
as if someone had killed last seat.
As you probably know,
over this past summer,
a Minnesota dentist named Walter Palmer
paid 55 grand to get permission today,
Tom Hunt and kill a
lion, a lion named Cecil,
an African lion considered
to be a national treasure
in the country of Zimbabwe.
This is a pretty famous lion,
sort of the star of that park
and been in a few studies.
So immediately there were allegations
of poaching Zimbabwe where Cecil was
killed, open up an investigation.
But what really caught our eye was the
reaction from the public lion killer.
The words painted on the
home of Dr. Walter Palmer.
People found out his home address
started sharing it online.
John Dam down the backlash,
threatening his livelihood.
Now protest Jews gathered outside his
office, posting signs on the lock doors,
branding him a coward and a killer.
He was forced to temporarily close his
business, vilified across the Internet.
There were attacks all over
social media and Youtube.
And warning this next minute
contained some pretty strong language.
You are truly
scrambled. The Earth wrote one Walter
fucker call no fucking demented.
This motherfucker is, may
you fucking burn to death?
I want somebody to take fucking drop dead.
What would happen?
[inaudible]
today
we bring you a story that we hope will
be a little bit of signal in all that
noise.
This is a story about the
strange relationship between
wanting to hunt and kill
an animal and wanting to save it
and it comes from my producers, Simon
Adler, one, two, three, four, five one,
two, three, four, five. All right,
so this story really started
from me in Salt Lake City.
This past February I went to the
western hunting and conservation expo,
sometimes referred to as
the super bowl of hunting.
Some walking through a this
airplane hanger sized a room set.
This massive convention center called the
Salt Palace. Over 40,000 people there,
gun manufacturers that were bowmakers.
There were call makers in the
single reed camouflage clothing,
apparel companies.
Well,
this place is rocking and I hope you're
having a good time and if you're having
a good time, I want to hear a big ie hall.
How
did the expo off this main floor?
There was a banquet hall where there
was an mc who is working in the crowd.
Well tonight, I want to
continue on a couple of
that we touched on last night, you know,
our greatest conservation
President Theodore Roosevelt
said the wildlife and its
habitat cannot speak for itself.
So we must, well, let me tell you,
we have and we will continue to speak,
but we've got to go further than speaking.
We're going to have to suit up in our
armor to go into battle to protect our
wildlife on our way of
life. Well, let me tell you,
we are at war brought on by the
extreme radical environmental movement.
If we're not vigilant, engage this enemy.
The most endangered species in
America could be the American hunter.
One of the things that surprised me
kind of right off the bat was talking to
people.
Everybody kept coming back to this idea
in hitting on this idea that like if it
weren't for us, if it
weren't for the hunters,
the animals would not be alive without
us onto them. They would go extinct.
I got that line over and over again.
There would be no animals other than hunt.
Basically what they mean by this is they
are the ones that are paying to keep
these animals around.
They are the ones who are
funding conservation and I
saw what that looked like
on the final night of the
expo Saturday night, uh,
when the organizers held this auction
and now's the time to open your
Wallets, Get out your checkbooks,
your credit cards. In fact,
we'll even take IOUs written
on the back of a Napkin.
Let's make some money for
wildlife. Let's do it.
Our first doctrine item tonight presented
the first couple of items,
they were just like guns.
It's an American made Ruger
rifle. But then item number three,
we're going to full curl stone.
A picture of the sheep pops up on
this jumbo screen up on the stage.
Big stone sheep, as you can
see right there. Big ones,
huge curling horns, thick brown coat,
beautiful color beauty that's
on the bucket list, brother.
That's all on the bucket list. So
the winner of this auction item,
what they're actually buying is the
chance to go up to Canada on this very
specific area and to shoot one
of these sheep to get a tag.
To shoot one of these sheets,
I have an opening bid of $30,000
that's what I'm talking about.
Let's go 32 and a half, 32 and a half,
one nine but I'm going to have to
get to an editor and I do that now,
but I've been unable to get 32 and a half
for one of the best stone units there
is. I'm 32 and a half down the
middle. Need 35 one time but about,
and nobody can find
35,001 diamond last call.
Sold them right over here
as $35,000 few items later.
Keep it rolling. We're a number six a
picture of a mooth comes on the screen.
Are All of you moose hunters
want a great Sharis Moose,
the kind of Moose that you know their
antlers ban out like giant wings.
Ladies and Gentlemen, I've got
$10,000 somebody can me 12 and a half,
12 and a half one down. But up until
now, but if I haven't had 12 and a half,
15 one time, but I'm going an have to
give anybody 1517 to half 17 and a half,
2022 a high of one when to put him
under 25 and hundred 25 and 31 down.
But I go now to get 35 on
time, but about an hour 40
wait, so how, how does the
conservation angle work?
Basically how this works is each state
has an agency that's responsible for
managing its wildlife.
And so if you're a hunter,
you basically have to buy a tag from
that state agency in order to shoot just
about any animal. For example, in Arizona,
Arizona is this grid of hunting
areas and you apply to a lottery.
For Zone B, I would really like
to be able to shoot a movie.
You put your $20 in,
this is typical and 60,000
if your name comes up,
you get your tag for $20 but it's possible
that you're not going to get one and
sometimes you have to wait 10 or 20 years.
Especially for these big game
animals. So what these agencies do,
they set aside a certain number
of these tags every year,
which are called conservation techniques
and what these conservation tags are is
like if you just give a bunch of money
right now, I did not see this common.
You have free range to do
what you want, hop the line,
shoot the animal you want. No Way.
$80,000 eight dead freaking dead and
then all that money goes back to those
state agencies for a land
management habitat restoration,
like we're talking millions of
dollars that get raised this way.
One auction item that I saw sold that
next special big game enhancement package,
which basically gave whoever wanted the
right to shoot just about any animal in
the entire state of New Mexico.
For a year. I'm 175 bucks.
No, 81 down, but I'm going
to have it of ADHD and avid.
I've been an avid 180 180 now able to
get 91 downloadable to navigate 90 90 90
yeah.
Sold it $230,000 one gentleman as close
to one so you can do a sound fair levels
and in fact the whole reason I hadn't
come to this convention was to talk to a
guy who had done an auction like this,
but in his case it kind of
blew up on it. Honestly,
did not expect to be in a position that
I am today. My name is Corey Knowlton,
c o r e y. K n.
O. W. L. T. O. N. Is that how you're going
to set, you're going to lead back? I,
you know I'll probably move
around a lot. Yeah. Okay.
Cornell has become kind of the poster
child of this idea of hunter conservation.
He's a Texas millionaire.
I met him in his hotel room right
across the street from the expo.
He was in a white tee shirt, blue jeans,
a little bit of stubble on his face.
And story goes back in January
of 2014 he was at next post,
super similar to this one put
on by the Dallas Safari Club.
I had my wife with me.
He was just walking the floor when he
bumped into a friend of his gentleman by
the name of John Jackson. Okay.
And John Jackson heads up a
group called conservation force.
So anyway,
John came to me and he told Corey that
he was worried that the Dallas Fart club,
they were auctioning off as an opportunity
to hunt a black rhino in Namibia.
The Namibian Ministry of Environment and
tourism had given them one tag to hunt
one black rhino and they were going
to auction it off what had to get old.
Now the black rhino is a critically
endangered species and are about 5,000 of
them in the world, about 2000 in Namibia.
And what the Namibian government does
is they auction off the older males.
What happens is the black round
gets older, it sees other rhinos,
it wants to attack them
oftentimes and kill them.
So the government will offer up those
problem rhinos for trophy hunting and then
use the money to protect
the others from poachers.
Is Poaching of the Black Ryan as a real
issue. Huge issue. Rhino Horn right now,
it goes, what's the number of
$60,000 a pound? Oh my God. Yeah.
It's worth like three times as much
as gold per ounce down. In any case,
Corey says, the reason that John
was so worried, John said, Corey,
there's been a, a,
a giant push of people
coming out against this.
It's literally a license to kill.
People don't want it to happen.
A permit to hunt down and kill one of
the world's most endangered animals.
You said, I'm really worried that um,
we're not gonna have someone
to bid this minimum bid.
His friend was worried that there were
going to be these Namibian ministers
there and they, they just didn't want
to be embarrassed. So John asked me,
he said,
would you at least bid the minimum
bid just to sorta like get the auction
rolling and as a friend,
if somebody that had been friends
with for over a decade, I said,
yes, I will do that. So
now to the auction, they started this
auction just like any other auction.
Eventually Corey makes this bid $350,000
thinking that would just go to the
other bidders. That's right.
I was like, you know what?
I'm going to do what I told you.
I'm going to follow through with my
commitment to when all of a sudden go once
going twice, boom. It happens. You know,
I'm just me. I'm just going old money,
Mr God, take people hunting.
But immediately I've got people
surrounding me, you know,
a giant line of people
congratulating me. He's like,
I didn't expect to be the
guy who'd get it by. Okay,
but next 48 hours, we now know who pay
$350,000 for a hunting permit to kill
an endangered black rhino and none
Namibia. A barrage of
threats started coming.
He's being bombarded with death threats
among the thousands of postings. I
hope the rhino rips you and half.
Do your children know what
a monster their father is?
I hope you get what you deserve or
short and painful existence. Corey says,
people threatened to murder his
parents to rape his wife to death.
I'm coming to your house.
I'm going to burn it down.
I'm going to put your kids
in a woodchipper. I'm going
to do it in front of you.
At any point in this, have you
been super enthralled by the idea?
Have you always wanted to
shoot a black rhino? Yes. Yeah.
You're gonna have to now
we're gonna have to be quiet.
I definitely haven't always
wanted to shoot a black rhino.
Have I always wanted to hunt for as
long as my, I remember. Yes. Okay.
Matter big journey in
life. When I was born,
we had literally nothing.
He told me he grew up in rural Missouri
in a small house, then trailer home.
His mom raised the family, his dad
loaded trucks at Safeway. Okay.
And we're trying to survive as a
family. So when Corey was eight,
we left Missouri in a,
in a Monte Carlo with $2,500 in the bank
and a dream to make it in this world.
Okay. So by the time I was 15, we
had moved all over the United States.
His Dad picked up jobs in Arizona, Texas.
I'm going from school to school to school.
I didn't really have the benefit of
getting in any sports teams or whatever.
But the one thing I did is I had a dad
that worked his butt off every day and I
didn't get to spend much time with him.
So then when we would go want to go do
things, Hey dad, let's go dove hunting.
It's duck season. You
know, and he loved that.
He mentioned this one time
when he was 11, we'd go out,
I have shotgun in my hand to doves fly
up and I shooting in both of them died.
One shot fell right there. Okay.
I went over there, got the doves,
went through cleaning them. Okay.
And preparing the cook them and just
being in that moment and not worrying
about, um, you know,
other problems that you met that we all
go through in life and just having a
nice quiet town. And my dad, I looked
at it as a privilege to go hunting.
I didn't look at it like, Hey,
it's my right to go out
and take some animals live.
I look at it like this is
an awesome opportunity.
I get to go spend with
my dad outside. Now.
As I became older, I became
more interested in hunting
or learned about Bose.
I want to learn about hunting.
I was ate up with it by the time he
was in his mid twenties. He says,
and this was right around the time his
dad hit it big in the oil industry.
He was leading hunts all around the world
from the North Pole to as far south as
you could hunt in New Zealand,
Nepal, Papa New Guinea.
So I've seen the whole world and he says
somewhere in the middle of all of those
trips, he realized that
there's a big fight out there.
This large bio mass of humanity is taking
over the world and wildlife doesn't
exist by accident anymore,
and so he started thinking about not
just hunting these animals but preserving
them and keeping them here.
All of which is to say when he won that
auction without meaning to and started
getting all those death
threats, he didn't turn back.
What on earth is keeping you so
steadfast and going ahead and doing this?
I think I would've thought
I shouldn't have done this.
I was willing to do this and it may have
not been what I planned on that I was
willing to do this based on a
commitment to I may do a friend.
I made a commitment to my family.
I made a commitment to
conservation as a whole. Look,
this was never about me going over
and taking a black rhinos live.
Like finally I get to achieve the xen
at of life and killing this black rhino.
Give me a break.
It was about method of conservation to
keep black rhinos on the face of this
earth. You are saying that you're
doing this for conservation.
Your detractors will say, they will say,
you say you are only doing
it for conservation when
you are really doing it for
no, I'm not saying
that's what you've said.
I'm saying that this is what they
will throw at you. You are only,
you were saying you're only
doing it for conservation.
Well all you are actually getting out
of it is some sort of satisfaction.
And can you talk for a minute about God
for more than a minute about it? Okay.
All right. Sure. I enjoy the act
of hunting. Can I tell you why?
Could I wrap that up in a real pretty
burrito for you to be able to eat and
understand and it tastes good? No,
but I can tell you that I care
about the survival of these pcs.
And do you understand why people have
a hard time wrapping their mind around
that you believing that and simultaneously
wanting to kill an animal or does
that just does not compute to you at all?
I mean at what point were
we're getting redundant.
They're missing the whole boat. We
don't have one without the other.
Okay.
If we want wildlife to be
around for future generations,
we have to understand that that
wildlife has to have a value.
If it doesn't have a value,
especially in the continent of Africa,
it's going to be gone. And here he
made a sort of economic argument.
He said you've got to keep in mind
that living next to a black rhino,
not just talking about it, but
actually living next to a black rhino,
it's a nightmare.
I mean who wants to live next door
to a raging psychopathic beast?
It's killing things. No one. So in
just very purely economic terms,
it has a negative value.
But what Corey will tell you and what
conservation organizations like World
Wildlife Fund and various others will
tell you is by him paying $350,000 to
shoot one, he is creating a
positive value for that animal.
He's creating jobs for game wardens.
He's creating jobs for trackers.
So you've got to look at the net
benefit. It's there. And so what,
what is the common ground here?
Because you guys want the same things
and yet there's somehow this, no,
we don't want the same conservationist
in general to be common ground has to be,
do you or do you not want to see
black rhinos on the face of the earth?
And I think everyone agrees that
they do, but I think even, no,
I think they do. I, I as their actions
are speaking louder than their words,
they're all, I think to
a lot of people there,
these neo-colonial sentiments here that
you are this guy who has a lot of money
and you are paying a lot of money to
go to Africa to shoot this thing and I
think that that causes
a reaction in certain people.
Do you think the amount of money plays
into it or no, to take a break for ones.
Okay.
Okay. When did you, you, you can say you
don't want to answer anything or that.
No, I want to give you the best possible
answer. Do you understand that? No,
I didn't get, try it. Okay.
I'm really trying to an emotional
level where I'm like, God Dang Man,
I want these people to
get some fucking fat.
I just don't know if I'm going
to be able to, we can stop. No,
you don't have to stop.
Just give me a second.
And I know that the words
I put out mean something
and I don't want to do to service.
I don't feel like I'm letting people
down and I'm not a radical psychopath.
You can see that. Okay.
Just something I believe in.
I can believe in these animals and
I believe that I want them here.
But I also understand
that death is inevitable.
Okay.
But the depth of this
bcs doesn't have to be.
And so
I'm putting myself through this because
I believe that it's right because I've
seen that it's right. And I'll go down
and I will sit next to people in Africa,
both indigenous and non indigenous
that have the exact same belief.
And they want these animals, they love
them, they want their kids to see it.
They know that one night when the stars
are above and they're sitting there with
their family and lion roars and a distance
that they feel that they feel what it
means to be afraid of it. They
feel what it means to respect it.
They feel what it means to love
it and they want that to continue.
And I want that to continue
in in a realistic view,
a realist view.
I believe I have a grasp on what
it takes for that to continue.
[inaudible]
thank you for being showing it.
I don't have any guns. Okay.
So that conversation happened over
six months ago. At that point, the,
the hunt was totally in limbo. He was
still receiving death threats. Uh,
animal welfare organizations like
Humane Society of the United States were
lobbying and petitioning
to try to stop the hunt.
And what it all really hinged on was
a decision to be made by us fish and
wildlife under the endangered species act.
It's illegal to import the carcass of
an endangered species into the United
States unless you can prove that by
killing and importing that animal,
you are helping the species. As a whole,
so that's what us fish and
wildlife had to decide.
Would Cory killing and importing that one?
Black Rhino help black rhinos as a whole.
March went by April and then
in early May I got a text from Corey
that just read. Let's talk tomorrow.
[inaudible]
coming up.
We take a trip.
[inaudible]
my name is Courtney and I'm calling
from Johannesburg South Africa.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
One information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is
supported by Google and Squarespace.
Make your business official
with Google and Squarespace.
When you create a custom domain and
a beautiful business website with
Squarespace, you'll receive
a free year of business,
email and professional tools from Google.
It's the simplest way to
look professional online.
Visit squarespace.com/google
to start your free trial.
Use the offer code document for
10% off on your first purchase.
Google and Squarespace. Make it
professional. Make it beautiful.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Morgan Stanley.
Your son has a gift for gymnastics.
Your daughter has her eye on a little
startup in the valley and you want to
retire early.
How do you create a wealth plan that
reflects all the complexity of a modern
family?
Start with a financial advisor who
understands individuals and knows how to
bring families together around
both shared and personal goals.
More information@morganstanley.com
slash conversations Morgan Stanley Smith
Barney LLC member. SIPOC.
Pleasure. Bye Bye.
All right, we are off the
plane walking into the airport.
I suppose this would be the first time
we've actually stepped foot in Namibia.
The uh, the destination. I'm Jen.
I'm Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Back to our board. Simon Adler. Okay,
so days after getting that text message,
I land in Namibia. Meet back up with
court. Today we're in Windhoek, Namibia,
so 13th of May Thousand 15.
This is Simon's big day to
interview local officials,
professional hunters in
any bum on the street.
That once the comment and how
long have we been traveling for?
Probably like closer to 48 hours. Now
you're feeling all right at this point?
Well a lot better now. I'm just getting
off the plane and fill in the wind.
Yeah,
the airport is tiny. We get through
customs and everything and immediately,
I'm Simon Simon, I'm 18
nice to meet you man.
We're met by the Ph
Hindi van here, the p h.
I am a professional hunter,
the professional hunter requested by
Cody Knowlton to assist him on his hunt.
He's sort of the manager of this entire
project. Big Dude, scraggly beard,
short shorts. We need to
go and pick up our stuff.
He leaves us out of the airport. So
what does the day's agenda hold for us?
Sort chaos out. Throw it in chaos.
Your chaos just started my
friend. So we get in his truck,
start driving.
Do you mind if I ask you some questions
while we drive here but ain't going on?
And I immediately just realize what a
headache putting all this together has
been for him. Oh
10 million phone calls,
meetings after meetings with the
Minister of Environment and tourism.
Adolfous checking with local offices
all to help them figure out which is the
best rhino for Corey to
shoot. So they had their list,
but so how many at this point you know
exactly which one you'll be going after
or are there a couple? The main base
we've identified that is two rhinos.
We can then remove from that area,
both male aggressive post reproductive.
We gonna try to get on one of
these two animals and try to run,
move it as professionally as
we can possibly do. Right.
So we're at the a ministry
of Environment and tourism.
This is apparently a meet and greet.
Later that day we stopped to shake hands
with the permanent secretary, Simeon.
Nick Gumbo.
Okay. I want to welcome you all.
He gave this kind of prepared speech
about how trophy hunting is a big part of
why Namibia is considered the gold
standard of conservation in Africa.
This program, as he says,
to have a wildlife groin.
Previously our wildlife
was almost say declining,
could like an elephant with less than
1000 but now we have plenty of them.
We don't know where to put in
in descending thousand. So Amini now.
So you've been so successful that
you have to deal with the surplus.
Yeah, the lower type of species,
we heavy dead. They green classmen.
Fast forward to the next morning.
It's 4:46 AM I doubt that Simon nor I got
any sleep last night despite all that.
So Moon's going to get
her before you through.
He was in high spirits.
Yeah. I woke up this morning.
It was drizzling rain around the curb.
Came a passenger train
first thing and bring it down to
the his firearm and the ammunition.
Big Knives and things. So we can scan
a little rhino Monday morning. Oh,
you think he was on the phone taking
care of final details and much to my
chagrin that there was this crew
of CNN reporters hanging around
once everything was loaded.
We took off for the airport.
Should I leave you here Corey?
Yeah. And I waved them off. Okay.
I'm happy hunting. Good
luck. Thanks ma'am.
You what? What was that again? You're
wave. I don't understand. I uh,
I wasn't able to go on the
rhino hunt itself. What? I know,
I know you're seem
disappointed, but in number one,
a hunting party can only be so large in
Namibia and with these three CNN guys,
they're the, the party was just full.
Um, but you also have to understand CNN,
I was in the country illegally.
Um, I had no press pass.
I had no pressing visa. So this was
like, oh, I've got to keep my head down.
Okay, this is this. Yeah,
that is our fault. Um,
so are you telling me the story is over?
Is that what you're basically saying?
No, no, don't worry.
Cory's personal camera man.
He promised to give me all of his audio.
So we do have the audio
and we'll get to that.
But while they were headed up north,
I actually ended up going east and where
I went totally unexpectedly made this
model of conservation and how it works,
like really finally clicked
into place for me. Uh,
do you mind just telling me your
name and where we are at? Oh,
my name is [inaudible]. My
name is Estelle [inaudible].
I'm a sort of the owner of these
concerns. I'm going to keep you company.
All right. Sounds good Andre.
And it's still swan and
pull own the Aro game farms,
which are a series of huge slots of
land that they've fenced in in total.
They have like over 200 square miles
of land that actually used to be filled
with cattle end know 15,
16 years ago we converted
into a game farm.
Basically they decided to get rid of
all the cattle and bringing all these
animals. They've got your rafts,
they've got two different species of
Zebra Willdabeast our two beast in all.
They've got 29 different
species, including how many black
running around the property here.
Uh, up until about three weeks ago,
they within the, now we, uh, we've got
11. So one of the hunting guides, Steph,
a statue bear at the Aro
game lodge is in Namibia,
told me that they actually just
had a rhino born on the property.
And in fact they've had several throughout
the years born on this property.
And he took me out to find what were
you gonna look for signs and keep always
building. So what should I be looking for?
If I'm going to be of any
help here on the distance,
it'll just look like a big gray
rock pit. You really got over Kenai.
You're driving through this really tall,
thick grass that kind of envelop the car.
It was almost like we were
driving through a cloud. It's,
this is the Kolari sour
grass. It's a real thick,
it's almost like the mice
can run on top of it.
Yeah, and after searching
and searching and searching.
Yeah.
Have, we've just spotted the
own. Oh Shit. There it is.
Like a hundred yards away. Oh Man. Okay
one. Okay. Shit. It's pointing at us.
So he's noticed us now. He's probably
heard the vehicle. So you know,
we're still at a very
safe distance. I'm just,
I want to get us into the shade and then
we can have a closer look and you can
put the binoculars up from taking
a real good look at it. Oh Man.
Looking through the binoculars and
he's just pointed straight at us.
His head's moving left
to right. Left to right.
I think this is a bull boy
that looks at things. God,
it looks like a dinosaur. It doesn't,
it is a very prehistoric looking animal.
He didn't, you were there.
Oh yeah. He was totally looking at us.
I'm going to put the binoculars on
and seat. He's trotting away from us.
He started moving away from us
to cut these tiny looking legs.
So when they run they have
to kind of shuffle along.
I think if the grass was in
that youth would laugh at him.
The way they move it's,
and he's quite comical,
very lucky to, to found one Jesus
that we were tailing behind it.
And the crazy thing is this huge
animal that weighs like over it ton.
Oh and it is on the move. It's
thinking move like 30 miles per hour.
We are currently driving at about 15
kilometers an hour and he's getting away
from us, kind of left us behind.
So he wants nothing to do with us.
He's moving off the, at one
point before it took off. Um,
we actually got close enough
that with the binoculars on,
Steph was able to get
a good look at its ear.
The Blues of the project initially have
all got earmarks and this one doesn't
actually have an earmark in it. So perhaps
this one was born on this property.
What's the, how does that work? How did,
how did the rhinos get to be
on this property? Uh, the, the,
the Ministry of Environment Tourism, uh,
had been in touch with the owner of
outer game nudges. Government said, hey,
you've got all this land,
will you take a couple of these rhinos
and protect them for us? And they said,
sure. You know, we
started off with a couple,
three rhino and the numbers grew and it
becomes this like strange foster care
type situation.
Each year we have to take photos of them
and we build up a portfolio and then we
can send it into met.
It's interesting that like
they are breeding here.
So there are more of them now than there
would have been if they hadn't been
moved here. Yeah. Yes,
exactly. And another thing, uh,
we were unlucky last year. We
actually, we lost two runners.
Steph said he wanted to show me
something, uh, drove for about 10 minutes.
Then he stopped the car at this small
clearing, almost no grass, one lone tree,
kind of an eerie Phineas. So I sort of
feel when I stumbled across this place.
Oh Man.
And can you just describe what
we're looking at right here?
Boone's just got that all over the
red sand of the calorie bleach.
White bones against red,
red sand. See a FEMA.
We can see some positive spine as
well. Is that a rhino? Yeah, this,
it's always, it's just unreal. Wow.
Can you see that there?
We got out of the car and like
actually like held these bones. Oh God.
Wow. How did that happen?
That it was the dominant bu I
was fighting with a younger bull,
the two squared off and the older one
ended up goring the younger one with its
horn,
or at least we think fortunately the
young old passed away so it killed it.
Then this, this older bull that
had just killed the younger one,
Steph told me it then went up to this
female wanting to reproduce and the young
female wasn't ready. She
wasn't mature enough yet.
He kept forcing himself on
her over and over until,
till she couldn't any longer.
I guess it would happen in nature as well.
It's just unfortunate that
they had to be. Yeah. Um,
so yeah, they would have been even
more, but, uh, nature took this course.
We didn't get involved. And so it is,
Steph explained to me that it
was these type of black rhinos,
these older aggressive bowls that get
auctioned up for guys like Corey to come
over and shoot and then all the money
that's been paid for it is going back or
going back into a anti-poaching
unit is going back into conserving,
uh, rhinos.
And it's nice to see such a large sum
of money coming in for a good cause.
So he believes in this
program. But personally I,
I'd never be able to, to shoot the
a black rhino.
I don't know. And why, what,
what about your personally wouldn't
shoot her rhino eyes for me.
Let me have Konrad
explain why. Well, no, I,
they know it's difficult to say, but the
doesn't tickle me.
Who's catching visit the [inaudible] over
the next couple of days at the lodge.
As I was hanging out with kind of these
tourists from all over the world who had
come here to be wined and dined and then
go out and shoot stuff in the morning
and afternoon Steffes ambivalence
started to make a deep sort of sense to
donate. Tommy, Tommy, Tommy,
Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, for instance.
I spent a lot of time with this guy,
Stefan Lindstrom. I'm from Sweden,
middle-aged there with
his family on vacation.
We decided six years ago
that we will go to Africa,
so I'm very happy to be here today.
This is six years in the making for you?
Yeah, you can see,
so it works in Volvo's corporate
office and he's a big trophy hunter.
Maybe you actually, to show
you some picture from my home,
do you have laps on the wall
already? Start to show him?
It's far too and after the
camp we have at least 50 Mars.
I got to follow him on a few
hunts. Him and his guide.
My name is Benjamin scrubber
scrape. It is my pseudonym.
Okay.
One of the hunts we spent about two and
a half hours searching for different
animals,
stocking different animals and then in
the distance so we still have very nice.
What about Buddha? We finally
found a waterbuck, which is what?
It's kind of like a reindeer, but uh,
it has these two big long horns
that kind of shoot backwards.
Almost like spears. Big Animal. Yup.
I guess don't [inaudible]. We're
just going to close and see.
We hopped down from the car and just
start kind of slowly moving towards it
through the grass type of
element is the top for me.
This weekend or this holiday,
Steven told me he had a list of animals
he was hoping to shoot and this was at
the top of this one. I think it's
just such a beautiful big animal.
That's why the game lodge charges $2,800
to shoot one. Okay. They went above us.
Yes sir. He said, okay,
okay, let's go and see.
Okay.
There's light wind or walking through
Shin length grass there, shrubs to the
left and the ride every like 10 minutes.
We'd stopped to measure how far away
it was. It's about two, 600 meters.
Take about the, tried to manage to
call, but all the close to that.
Okay.
Eventually we got just a couple
hundred feet away from it.
The animals off in the distance.
It's just kind of pacing that
then pulls out this tripod,
sets it up and Stephan
gets into positions.
Yup.
The buck stumbled a few paces and
he's done. [inaudible] falls down,
but then it gets right back
up and stumbled forward.
Put another bulletin one in this one,
one in the first shot. Didn't kill it.
Shoot rather high because to
a lot of girls at this point,
Ben seems tense.
He doesn't like that because it's like
he knows that the animal is suffering.
Uh, so the dog takes off,
runs after it and just keeps it at bay
by kind of circling it and we start
moving towards it. Let's
go closer. Let's try
[inaudible] next.
Okay.
Again, second shot doesn't kill it. Falls
down, gets back up, falls down again.
At least on the, just
it's arriving in the grass.
Ben Now seems pretty upset.
I Dunno what
you showed the the first
time, but rather high
school came up the fried. Yep.
And the third shot, wheat doesn't
kill it. Sweet. Don't fuck
shit. This is no fun. Is this
[inaudible]
finally fourth shot.
It goes limp dem [inaudible] shots.
It's like on the ground and the
leg is still kicking a little bit.
But if it's done well, it's a nice,
I am so happy. I'm so happy. This was
the top of the list for me this weekend.
So this artist perfect
is very nice feelings.
So
seeing it up close,
it can be emotionally difficult.
But when you pan out, it's pretty clear.
The numbers showed that this
Namibian model is working. Um,
wildlife numbers on private land have
gone up by almost 80% since the government
allowed people to buy, sell and
shoot wildlife on their land.
And since trophy hunting of
the black rhino was legalized,
that population has grown by like 30%.
But from my face, not all African
conservation is they're on board.
I talked to a guy named Richard Leakey,
super famous anthropologist who also
directed Kenya's wildlife program for
awhile. And I asked,
what is your stance on this
idea of sustainable use
a of wine? Listen to me, I think it's
utterly ridiculous. Well, you know,
w w w if a father cannot afford to
pay school fees for his children,
does he say to somebody,
you can rape my daughters,
I can get the money to pay
for school fees. I mean,
I think we've got to set some standards
in life and I think this is nonsense.
What,
what this argument is about killing
wild animals so that they can be looked
after. Absolutely said the wrong message.
This was the big issue he took with
Namibia strategy. Yes, you can.
You can afford to lose five runners
from a breeding perspective,
but does that send the right message?
He then told me a story about when he
took over Kenya Wildlife Service in 1989
at the time, things were dire.
Elephants were being killed at an
alarming number and we will get to lose.
I elephants totally
poaching was on the rise
and his predecessors had
actually confiscated a huge
number of elephant tusks
from these poachers
12 times, 12 times. Once you saw it,
you thought that's a lot of ivory.
And they recommended to him,
sell designery make about $3
and then use that money to help fight
poaching the patient. But leaky said no.
What he did instead was he built a giant
tower out of that ivory [inaudible]
project,
millions of dollars in ivory taken by
poachers burned more than 12 tons of
contraband, lol, tons of illegally poached
ivory worth several million dollars
fun for three days. Punk
television, newspapers,
magazines, radio.
It was this massive PR stuff to draw
the world's attention to the plight of
elephants. And part of what he
was saying in that was like,
we have to value these things
beyond their dollar value.
We have to respect the intrinsic value
of these creatures. Well, wait a second.
If you're burning a bunch of ivory,
aren't you in effect increasing the
value of the ivory cause now there's just
less of it out there. Let's say you're
looking at the supply end of it, right?
Um, yes. By reducing supply
that would push up price.
Leaky was attacking the demand side.
What an impact it had around the world.
Pinion changed overnight. He
said it woke the public up.
People stopped buying ivory and the
market for ivory. It just crashed.
Up to that time we'd been losing about
three and a half thousand elephants to
4,000 elephants a year and a year later
we were losing at most 60 really it has
an enormous impact.
My friend getting a public that
supports conservation of wildlife,
that's a huge challenge
and we just can't afford,
I think just send up the wrong messages,
but the problem with that is finding
the right message is getting harder and
harder.
I called various conservation
organizations and one guy
who I talked to told me
that their average age of
donor is getting older.
More and more people are
just living in cities.
Less people are having
positive experiences in the
natural world at a young age
and so he said that they're going to
have to continue focusing on people
focusing on us. This message
of what does wild life give us?
What does it do for people?
This is our third day up in the area.
Still no luck and we're
just going to keep at it.
Back in Namibia,
after three days of bushwhacking through
this dense vegetation up in the north
of the country, Corey and
his crew finally got on the
tracks of the right rhino. The local guy
says, we found a rhino that had guild,
another rhino that had killed another
rhino. So we're gonna follow this one,
make a hundred percent sure
that it's the Ryan one,
and then we'll try to take it if we can.
So for the next couple of hours they
track the animal looking for basically
footprints anywhere that
has marked its territory.
So we're not dragging this like probably
a couple hours now bumped at least
twice.
We were, had walked at this point
just about 12 miles. It was very hot.
You can see how pick it right here. Pretty
intense.
The grass was so thick that they really
couldn't see more than about 30 feet in
front of them. And eventually they
find, you can see this as the rhinos,
a pile of rhino feces that still
warrants, still very moist,
doesn't mean it's fright. This is,
we're not more than an hour behind that
animal right there and you can see the
Dung beetles and everything in
it. And so this nmos with Ada.
We sat there for a few minutes,
right, gathered our thoughts.
So it lets you line it out.
We're going to do what you say.
And then about two hours later
we've heard some noise from my left all
by t is running fees with a giant saber
on its head.
It was like lightning.
So we also didn't get
it with the first shot.
The first several shots
did not kill this thing.
It ran off and then they had to start
tracking it again and it just wounded.
Yes, we followed it. I would
say 10 minutes. I don't
know. I looked over there,
I saw it. It wasn't lying down at
this point. It was standing up,
but it had already fallen
down twice. It was dying.
And then
I shot it a few more times.
The last thing you do is once
you are really assured it's dead,
you can touch its eye and if
it doesn't blink, it's gone.
So did you go touch your tie?
Absolutely. In a moment like that,
is there some sort of,
is there a conversation going on now
that the animal is dead and you're not?
No,
we just kind of looked at everybody
looked at each other and made sure we were
okay. There wasn't a whole lot
of talk right then in this case,
but it was an emotional moment for me.
So the mate,
we've been sitting here skin in this
animal so far this morning and now we're
about to roll it over skin the other
side and then just take the quarters off
just like any other animal that you
would if you were on a hunting trip.
They loaded up all the meat to be shipped
off to a local village and they kept a
little bit of it for themselves.
Cook.
And my first piece of black rhino me
here on the coals next to the CarGurus,
right? Here's the moment when we've,
everybody here has started
eating some of this black rhino.
So it's just a part of a part of
hunting and a part of being a human.
So it's a pretty unique and
awesome moment right here.
I'm not really morally outraged
by it. I'm, maybe I'm a little,
but I think you might be vulnerable
if you insist that your enthusiasm for
hunting is part of the balance of
nature, but I think it's perfectly,
you don't have those canine
teeth for eating salad,
and I understand that people don't like
it any more than they wouldn't like
going and killing the lamb of
the lamb shots they eat. Well,
what about that doesn't mean that it's
wrong hunting. It's part of who we are.
Now it may be a bigger part of who
I am than you are and that's fine,
but when wildlife populations abound is
when they're managed by humans beings.
The alternate model might be a view
of humans that's different from yours.
I think you assume that because we are
smart and because there are so many of us
that inevitably we will bump into
them and when we do we will win.
And thus your calculations,
the alternate model might be
that because we are smart,
we might create a space where
we won't bump into them.
Now you're now, you're not in the real
world. We're dealing not in reality.
Okay, I'm, I'm living in a world that
matters. And that's real. So it's not,
it's not a dream scenario.
And it's not saying, okay,
well let's just create this. Unfortunately
these animals don't have that time.
So I'm not trying to outsmart anybody.
It's just a traditional
method that's worked.
And until somebody comes up with a
methodology that we could look at and say,
this is a better way,
I'm going to continue to fight and
believe in the traditional model.
So now we're going to ask
ourselves these questions.
How do we really on an individual basis,
value this animal's survival on earth?
Do you really value it?
Do you value it past making 75 characters
into your iPhone and tweeting about
it? Do you value it passed
watching animal planet? To me,
I know, and I care,
and I placed an extreme value financially,
physically, emotionally on the
survival of the black rhino.